hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot I
know I know still the same day but I
took a little breather I petted chica I
feel better I think I'm gonna do better
I think everything's gonna go better for
me now so break every box without dying
there in a special gym yeah that's not
gonna happen not gonna happen to me dark
and spooky oh you're my light oh you're
the light of my life can you make sure I
don't die
that'd be great this seems almost like a
bridge level which I don't like at all
[Music]
okay I don't know how I woulda lost it
in that timeframe you know I'd almost
think that this place was aesthetically
pleasing if I wasn't so pissed off and
bleeding through my eyes but now that I
can see you didn't got a checkpoint
right here and I'm happy about that I
don't know why there's a checkpoint here
and there wasn't in the other guy I
didn't think I was gonna make that I
don't know what happened there I
panicked I'm sorry oh man the
perspective is a little weird now why is
a perspective weird is that by design or
is that something else seems like things
are frozen they are I don't like that
I can't wait for things ah okay I get it
now
ah right I've missed the life but you
know I don't need it I got a life after
this I'm gonna go get other lives to buy
killing things rats no don't come near
me I'm angry
oh the checkpoint was right
it's okay because at least I feel like
I'm getting through this level alright
no idea I slowed down then down you know
slow down you don't slow down you just
keep moving
Oh lose all my lives freak you just keep
going just keep going trust it trust in
the heart of the cards trust in the
heart of the cards got it nailed it this
got that okay
and the rats are gonna come that's okay
I got a projects Ellucian okay never
mind I guess I'm not actually gonna hit
them haha okay checkpoint there no rats
I said no okay why am i using him okay
here we go again get this get that
alright don't know why that got missed
but whatever I'll just accept that as
truth sure ah ah okay mind oh oh you
were just sitting there in the darkness
a little ghostly and scary but that's
okay okay that was dumb of me yeah to
you ah there we get it now
wait I'm always in such a goddamn hurry
why there's no point in being in her
waxy and this level there is because of
the time when that but that's okay I
don't I'm in the darkness but I can make
it I can still do this oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god I'm right there hey
I made it great I did it have I even
looked at you once this time Thanks
thanks for being here with me at least I
got through that level in quick order I
didn't waste forever on jaws of Darkness
I don't know what you mean by jaws of
darkness but I'm guessing it's not gonna
be very fun for me actually that last
level was pretty fun I got a minute this
game is fun I don't want people getting
the wrong idea that I don't actually
like the game I actually do like the
game I think the game is made very well
except for a few jumping conundrums here
and there but other than that like the
game actually it's fun it's varied like
it has a lot of things Oh
has a lot of things going for it but I
mean like I'm not a fan of everything
but I'm enjoying myself a little bit or
else I wouldn't keep going after this
like I wouldn't keep like destroying my
brain trying to get through this if I
wasn't at least a little bit enjoying
myself which I am I think anyway maybe
I'm just delusional
maybe it's like Stockholm Syndrome
stockholm stockholm syndrome you know
that syndrome where where you you've
been captive for so long you start to
fall in love with your captor or you at
least start to feel close to him her it
yeah it's not a good thing but you know
maybe that's it
you know how would I know how would I
know how would I know all the screaming
and ranting and raving I'm that's
enjoying myself sure okay yeah I believe
that markiplier you're not a big old
lying piece of [ __ ]
Marc a liar Marc it liar where am I
going where are you taking me
okay I guess alright Jessica did that
sure why jump on that I must write hey
get back here I need to jump on you hey
come on now don't be a don't be like
that
oh I heard that Oh boink yeah oh it's
just vanished
not necessarily dead just jumped into
another dimension hope whoa that idea oh
I don't like this at all
Oh oh my god I do not like okay well
misjudge that that I don't like this
don't like this don't like it I don't
like that this would be literally
impossible at the directional buttons
here we go I'm doing it with the joypad
by the way if anyone's curious about my
gaming skills right now my program okay
hey left that's plenty right that's
plenty I'm gonna do great I'm gonna go
and do great things I'm gonna make
everybody proud of me everyone's gonna
be happy about this okay ah oh yes okay
all right I don't know
what [ __ ] what what is thumping
I don't like it is it these stones hello
[Music]
I'm not gonna be able to do what I need
to do and I can't do anybody else notice
I turned into the world's greatest
rapper when I'm angry just keeps I'm fly
like it a thousand words a minute I've
never spoken more clearly than when I'm
pissed off okay okay this time don't be
in a hurry that's an option life is
about taking your time now that doesn't
seem right
life is about hurrying in a [ __ ]
because we don't know how much longer we
[Music]
come on now why did I hesitate I
hesitated there and that's the only
reason I died I was so close to the
checkpoint and then oh it always happens
it always happens like this it always go
down like that
and then I'm gonna game over and I'm
gonna start this whole goddamn level
over again well I just had to say
something about the last time
okay that was super weird I thought it
was a different pattern for a second
there and I I don't know why that vexed
me like I was I just wanted to take my
time with it and analyze it that a lot
of good it's gonna do me when I'm out of
here
why what the hell is going on with that
what excuse me that I thought something
was weird last time oh my god why that
oh my god the perspective is so weird in
this area I don't know why my brain is
not handling it I need so many more
lives oh god oh god oh my god
come on give me another life baby oh I
have definitely not gotten all those oh
god why did i think that was closer no
good I'm gonna lose it I'm gonna lose it
all away oh my god no no no no no no no
no no no no no don't do this to me not
now not now I'm so close I've made it so
far I had nine lives there I had so many
lives oh my god don't rush don't rush
you're not in a hurry nothing's bad
nothing's wrong everything's fine I'm so
close to another life yes yes yes okay
got another life that doesn't mean that
doesn't mean license to [ __ ] up did you
know what that was my fault
[ __ ] yeah I made it here okay let's go
to the bonus let's go to the bonus what
I went there were 122 boxes in entire
how did I not get that
oh really oh really oh really there's a
TNT up there okay all right that's okay
making it through the bonus sorry I just
my brain stopped working for a second
there I had to really think about what I
was doing with my life
[Music]
nice okay got some sweet lives got some
sweet lives sweet lives out of that one
replenish my stock and let's keep going
cuz I'm right here at the end and I
could [ __ ] it up very easily
oh oh oh my god he's about to get
destroyed oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
Oh God we're just gonna have to
time-lapse this one oh yeah face down
ass up that's the way oh god he's dead
no yeah he he's dead
okay oh he's dead oh yeah he's oh he's
very dead oh you're not dead
oh just minor brain babble is he seems
in better spirits he's good
great 65 I think that's a new record
where let's at least see what the next
level is let's just look let's just look
well this looks interesting
so I'm gonna be climbing again am i I'm
gonna be climbing again aren't I Castle
Machinery suggests that I'm going up a
wall again oh this doesn't look so bad
is that the exit hahaha I can't make
that
[Music]
oh I see it I see I see what you're
doing here
okay I gotcha well let me give this I
was literally about to say let me give
this a speedrun treatment gotta climb
all the way back up this Ducie tree okay
but I got this if I can just focus and
concentrate I can actually do this well
like I'd like to think I've gotten so
good at this game that I know I could
like to think that I'm so good at this
game now then I'm just a baby okay
back into the thick of it as if nothing
happened because nothing should have so
nothing dude I feel good about my life
choice just really fun to be a whole lot
of me yeah I'm going real fast and show
enough my skill now ok I'm back up our
BAE ignore my stupid song I sing songs
when I'm anxious just because like it's
the only way I can cope oh yeah I don't
need to jump on there that's fun okay
here we go now go win back the door eats
oh yeah baby where the [ __ ] MA going
oh that's cool
oh [ __ ] you almost touch me I don't like
that checkpoint don't eat it
cuz watch this let this do the work for
me apparently
okay well missed that jump a little bit
but I misjudge a lot of things in my
life so you know that's not gonna be the
first okay you know you almost you know
screwed me how did I overshoot that how
the fudge sickle did I overshoot that
okay god these pipes are just against
regulation ah not happy about this where
am I going now okay sure yeah
sure whatever Oh Vance I don't like that
okay well easy come easy go I guess ah
good toxic sludge just what I wanted I
don't know what I'm doing doot doot doot
doot doot point go down I guess Swink
dip get over that oh yeah I'm so over
you I don't know where you lead I don't
know where you lead I don't know what
you lead oh boy this is a whole lot of
why do they even bother calling it
something other than Apple's it's very
obviously apples oh don't do that okay
all right
oh boy oh yeah we're gonna make this
it's getting easier
now comes the speed run portion of this
exercise watch closely as I exercise my
school
well checkpoint hell yeah jump over that
you jump over that loop jump over that
hard alone go down okay you watch out
for this guy he's a prickly fella okay
here we go
skill skill skill skill skill skill
skill skill skill skill skill skill and
paying bills Oh God okay thirdly deadly
deadly boink
nearly daily daily boink okay I think
we're almost there
we gotta be almost there right oh hey
okay you know what how about you get a
face full of spinning fists spinning
fists
spinning fist spinning fist nice okay oh
god I didn't want to immediately go
okay I made it apparently this is not
cool bruh
not cool bruh yeah I can land on those
why did I try to jump over them god
dammit I don't know where I am all the
way over here oh hey life I hate life
yep
that's not good oh oh yes you know what
it's fine whatever it's fine I made it
through there with a good bit of skill
no all of you may be doubting me out
there but you know it's true I made it
through there with so much skill okay
only ten boxes mr. Barry lost all the
baggage but it wouldn't America the
guard huh so anyway that is all for this
episode I don't know how close I am to
the end of this game but I'm getting
closer so thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for rooting me on
down in the comments thank you for
cheering me at home wherever you be who
dr. nitrous Brio huh guy seems like one
of the find ler bosses so maybe I'll do
some more soon try to beat it so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]